GUEST SPEAKER 1:
So we also tried
to learn how to use processing.
It's pretty bare-bones,
but I guess--
so essentially, we have a
little widget and punch.
Oh.
So the set size right
now is set to eight.
Originally, we wanted to be
able to remotely control it.
So that's one count, and I'll
do two, three, four, five, six.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: You
can see that you've
set set size to eight.
So it'll stop when it's
eight, and then it'll recount.
We also have this thing that we
labeled "Temple" because it's
related to our game.
But it actually correlates
with how fast you're punching.
So if we smooth this
out, this is actually
telling you how fast you're
punching for each one.
Yeah-- and then this to average.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Average
set speed is pretty much
the eight different
punches that you
have divided by the
total amount of time
to do those eight punches.
So I can do my next set and be
like, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
And then we'll be on
set two or set three.
So it's pretty basic
right now, but there's
a lot of different features
that we could add with the gyro
if we had more time.
And if you have two hands,
then they could communicate.
Maybe we can show the game.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: OK.
So we have to
actually upload that.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: So
some other thing--
GUEST SPEAKER 1: This is
"Smoke on the Water," the song
that you're supposed to play.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: So it plays
the song for you first.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: And now
it'll say, your turn.
And that's just the first part,
which is like, bum, bum, bum.
So it'll be like, mm, mm, mm.
[COMPUTER BEEPS]
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Got it.
Yeah.
So yeah, it said, "Good job."
And then now it's the second
part, so you punch that beat.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: But
it's hard to hear.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
OK.
Yeah, you got it.
And then it goes on
to the next part.
And then basically, you cycle
through the different parts.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: I think
that's the part when it breaks.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: So ideally,
if we could actually
play the music on something
better than a buzzer,
I think it'd be a lot better.
[LAUGHTER]
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
But it was definitely
a really nice project
to learn how to use a
bunch of different sensors.
We also had a
heart rate monitor,
which was able to
get beats per minute,
but it was pretty inaccurate.
But it was nice to
learn to set it up.
We had an RFID sensor.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Yeah, the LEDs.
GUEST SPEAKER 1:
And we have LEDs
that depending on how hard you
punch, a certain amount of them
got lit up.
We just took them out, and
it was a free, fluid project
in terms of a good
beginner learning project.
But yeah, I think this is a
good example of a wearable
and how you can embed a
bunch of different sensors
to get different features.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]